well i i saw something you posted about
sauce um you rate things by sauce
yeah so what does that mean and where
did the sauce rating system come from
you know it started with um i've been
obviously with my kids a ton during this
break and so i found myself cooking a
ton of meals
yeah cooking meals for kids is such a
thankless gig yeah they think you're
like a short order cook i'm like
yeah i can't just whip that up so as
well as
i'll make things before i had kids i
just didn't cook very much
so i'll make something that is
really solid and their response will be
after a bite like
i'll take cereal instead and so
we started we've been watching a lot of
cooking shows
and so my way of getting cooking to work
with my kids is
rather than their themselves when i
present them the food they're
the judges on a cooking show oh my gosh
you're clever
well it makes it all of a sudden they
eat the whole meal because they're a
judge so they'll say like
i like the texture but i don't love the
cheese and the quesadilla and i'll be
like thank you judge how about you and
they'll have to take another bite and
blah blah blah
but we realized in doing this game we
didn't have
enough terms because they would they're
six they're twins so their numbers
aren't great so they would say like
i'd say out of 10 what is it they'd be
like 100 out of one
no that doesn't work so we created a
sauce
system 100 out of one and so we'd be
like all right so if you really
like something it's extra sauce if you
don't like it the sauce was bad
and so that's how we've been doing it
and then you know
that's the most clever like you should
write a parenting book because man
my son and my four-year-old is i can get
my girl my sexuality anything
especially if i bribe with some kind of
treat afterwards my son
will starve she will literally look me
and go
nope it's so tricky okay
um anyway so i'm gonna try this that's
what i'm gonna do i don't know if he'll
get that at four yet but maybe by the
time he's six
you